Das Gerücht ging, dass die russischen Truppen in der Tschechei einmarschieren.
Da waren wir gar nicht überrascht, denn wir haben in Gols, das ist im Seewinkel,
eine Außenstelle, die Funkaußenstelle war für das österreichische Bundesheer
und da konnte man sämtliche Bewegungen und auch Geräusche feststellen.
So waren wir am Tag vorher schon informiert
und ich habe der Truppe aber nichts gesagt damit sie gut schlafen können.
Aber dann ist um 5 Uhr Früh am nächsten Tag am 21. ein Alarmbefehl an uns gegangen.
Nach diesem Alarmbefehl war meine Kompanie um 8 Uhr
Vollmarschfähig bereit und wir hätten abrücken können.
Nun verzögerte sich dieser Zustand um 8 Stunden.
Die Truppe wusste zwar nicht was da los war, ich habe über Telefon mich beim Militärkommando erkundigt,
die haben gesagt, dass es da irgendwelche Schwierigkeiten gibt, eben zwischen Innenministerium
und Landesministerium, wer den Befehl zum Abrücken der Truppen in diese Einsatzräume gibt.
Alle an der Linie Mistelbach, Horn, Döllersheim, Zwettl bis Freistadt verlegte Truppen
durften diese Linie nicht überschreiten.
Wir wussten, dass vor uns, also nach Osten und nach Norden, die Gendarmerie
schon mit 960 Mann diesen Sicherungsdienst übernommen hatte im Einvernehmen mit der Zollwache.
Ich möchte sagen, dass die Truppe diese Verlegung gut verkraftet hat,
es hat keine disziplinären Verfehlungen gegeben.
Es wurde auch freizeitgestaltend gearbeitet, sie durften ins Kino gehen, geschlossen,
und verschiedene andere Programme besuchen.
Es lief alles bestens ab.
Eines möchte ich vielleicht abschließend noch sagen,
dass es sowohl die Jägertruppe und die verlegten Jägertruppenteile
als auch die Panzergrenadiertruppen entlang dieser Linie die ich vorher geschildert habe,
bedauert haben nicht mit ihrer Truppe direkt an der Grenze Sicherungseinsatz betreiben zu dürfen.